this is so weird cuz you you know when
your friends and family was so mean you
got them on your show it's awkward I
ended up marry your oldest son and and
and you got stuck with me more thank
goodness we've had I always have my
little moments with you because I know
we're friends and we're family but
you're always like that hero to me like
especially musically like you're just a
beast like a pioneer for women like it's
insane I think what's amazing about your
career is you're a businesswoman you've
conquered Broadway you've conquered TV
you've conquered movies animated film I
mean you've done everything you could
possibly want to do so like my question
is what is the next mountain because
you've done you've already mastered
everything I have mastered or conquered
anything I don't know I've just gotten
to participate people were nice enough
to let me be a part of I tell you what
I'd really love to do okay I want to do
an authentic western movie or a
television show a Western people would
love how love westerns there's so many
avenues now yeah like Amazon all the
things everywhere we can make this
happen
Kelly Clarkson says so right there
[Applause]
anything I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this